don't don't edit that part out either
because I love that the vaynernation is
gonna hear that you messed up and stop
it too soon what's that oh you didn't
have that part either oh you're really
killing me all right
ready on this episode I answer a bunch
of questions but the funny part is
they're here you keep asking questions
I'll keep trying to answer them
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
you're watching episode 26 of the ask
gary vee show fun fact about the number
26 is it's this man's best favorite
number everybody it's me as you can tell
different setting as you can tell I am
actually in New York City on an all day
event speaking with Seth Godin Dave
Ramsey an event so I decided to mix it
up and bring people backstage in the
green room with me it's this one's
actually green which one kind of makes
it funny and have them ask the questions
so let's just get right into it get in
here right tell the vaynernation who you
are
Garrett green from Nashville Tennessee I
wanted to ask you talked a lot about
challenging the main media source in
your business I know you brought up like
companies bringing like creating a golf
website it takes on Golf Digest and then
every once in a while is a sponsored
post and I know you've done it with
cheese ranked um for smaller companies
they don't have all the resources for
editors and content creators and such
way you're echoing for them is this you
think this is kind of the next evolution
it's going to become more of a product
people thanks for the question it's a
great question yeah I mean look this is
what I believe in and for small
businesses I recommend doing what I did
in 2006 which was look there's a
difference between BuzzFeed and Seth
Godin x' blog right there's a lot more
content every day there's a lot more
stuff but Seth puts out his best effort
once a day for me I did a wine show I
mean it's what I'm doing right now I
mean in theory I could staff up even
more than d-roc instead stunwin and and
put out QA shows all day long have go
the Oprah model and have people
underneath me there's a lot of ways to
go but if you believe in what I believe
in which is every business is becoming a
media company all of a sudden you're
taking hours away from staffing
strategizing selling
all the other things doing and you're
putting one two three hours into
becoming a media company and I do
believe that has enormous upside I mean
not much has changed for me since I
viewed the world in 2009 and wrote crush
it the only thing that's changed is I'm
even more confident I was right because
there's more of that happening we look
at the average fit the things I wrote
about in 2009 that people thought were
ridiculous like you know a 15 year olds
gonna have more people that they think
those famous on YouTube than in real
life that's now happening you know if
anybody has 15 year-olds let them in if
anybody has 15 year-olds in their lives
hit him you need me now I'm taping a
show do I have time yeah yeah no no
you're fine I was coming to ask about
this if you wanted the guys to be a part
yeah me grow those guys the guys I will
but let me bang out this show you know
you're not editing um so to me I would
just say if you believe in it and you
don't have the resources then respect
your belief and put in your time and
actually do it versus all the other
things you can be doing awesome thanks
mother next let's go tell the
vaynernation who you are
Nathan ruff be Nathan ruff calm and a
web design development company called
1-9 nice game nice blogging Tiger love
it love the plug good man question is I
feel like a lot of small businesses fail
because they refused to say who are you
asking a question of the vaynernation or
me let's go expose come ah good I feel
like a lot of small businesses fail
because they refuse to step what they're
not good at for example I suck at
accounting so I have somebody do
accounting for me but I see people you
know they suck at photography but
they're still doing their photography
and it's hurting a brand yeah they're
not accepting that okay your thoughts on
that cool thank you I mean I you know
again as somebody who's been following
my stuff I think we agree on this right
like I'm a big fan of going all-in and
your strengths and outsourcing or not
focusing on your weaknesses I I think
you've got a pegged right I think the
one thing is sometimes it's obvious
right don't get caught in the obvious
meaning it's obvious to you that you
suck at accounting it's kind of easy
right it's math like you probably also
don't want to or like doing it that's
easy it's the thing that's in the
shadows that's not as obvious there's
something you're doing right now that a
lot of people could do better than you
it's easy when you're an F at it and you
know you need an a but what about the
fact that you might be doing something
right now a tiger or somewhere else
where your a be at it but you could
afford to have somebody be an a at it
that's where people miss the mistake so
it takes deep self-awareness you know
I'm not a big believer in like try try
try harder to be better at this thing I
think it's a waste of resources energy
and happiness often now if you get off
on that kind of thing like persevering
knock yourself out roll how you want to
roll but for me big believer I'm betting
on all your strengths and trying to find
complements to your weaknesses how would
you like a new one for a scaredy like it
is cool when they're live they can got
follow-up how would you bring it up like
you know people with terrible website
doesn't work on a mobile device and
they're just not getting done just set
but okay they're not gonna get in walk
away or how would you bring up saying
hey you're not really good at now you're
asking me a sales question I think right
like are you saying to reach out to
somebody and say hey we should do that
for you even like from just a helping
providing value like hey you're not good
at this I don't think my companies are
right fit but you're not good at this
I'm just telling you like you know one
of the one of the things that I do tap
yeah the one of the things I do
tactically is just call people out on it
right like I'll reply to them publicly
on Twitter and say hey you just tweeted
wrong here's that you know my classic
like everybody does this wrong on
Twitter you know I'm not scared to do
you know my route is simple polite
polite polite you're not getting it and
I still care enough which is very rare
then I'm gonna drill you in your face
thanks man
enjoy next let's go I like this I like I
like this do you rock like a broom all
right my name is Nick parks and Gary I'm
just curious so let's say if you know
you were just born to be an entrepreneur
that's yes what you do is I believe in
that um well until you're an
entrepreneur like that you're just
you're not gonna be fulfilled
yes happy but talk to me about my first
18 years of my life yeah so that's my
question like yeah what point are you
being fiscally responsible and at what
point occasion is it just like analysis
paralysis where you think well I can't
go into it full-time yet yeah I need a
full-time job that's a tough question I
and now I understand what you're saying
so so are you saying let me make sure I
dissect this properly for people like me
that happened to feel that they are that
and then happened to be good at it it's
easy right because it worked out are you
asking me if you feel like you're an
entrepreneur but you're not good enough
to be an entrepreneur that can sustain a
lifestyle where you have to balance
something else what do you do maybe more
do you keep trying or
you asking actually apologize because
I'm recalibrating how long can I you
know go at it as thinking of an
entrepreneur until I have to wake up and
say wait a minute am i tricking myself
and let me get a little more practical
and jump off that train I mean more like
let's say you have a full-time job and
good pay good benefits knowledge if you
have a full-time job you're not an
entrepreneur so you have to understand
that is a very important part here right
you may have entrepreneurial tendencies
you may have aspiration to be an
entrepreneur but when you are an
entrepreneur you can't believe having a
job you can't believe Hitler said you
can't breathe now look maybe I'm the
extreme of it but you know the fact is
you know especially right now and
especially I'm guessing at some level
this is for you not your friend kind of
thing or it might be friend or might be
general you're so young that you have so
much less risk than the like when you're
18 to 29 in America today by all
standards to me that's your time to if
you're an entrepreneur you're being an
entrepreneur right you know if you're
ready in willing to take a job then you
have entrepreneurial tendencies and
that's the thing you have to figure out
but to me there is no such thing as an
under 30 year old entrepreneur that has
a job it doesn't exist all right thank
thanks chef get in here you notice her
from this comment section she's also
shuffle is that all right calm down calm
down
oh that shuffles that one all right
anyways so you know I want to piggyback
on that because you were capturing a
certain demographic and age group so I
want to represent all of those who are a
little bit older I mean so I'm asking it
for that okay you know people who
already have kids financial commitments
homes mortgages blah blah blah so when
you keep talking about how do you audit
your time how do you analyze what
character traits can you speak to the
older folks between the 30s
50-somethings okay how to God and make
it happen or or analyze do you really
have what it takes because at this point
these folks probably have 10 plus 15
years of experience in their endeavors
already the one thing I think fiction
the one thing that I think is
interesting is let's break down the
question a little bit differently which
is
you know there's a level of never being
able to fully make it but still being in
a process where you enjoy the effort to
get there this is not an awesome game
I'm okay with somebody being a nuanced
entrepreneur where there's a full-time
job and they're trying to make it happen
and that almost because what happens is
you're almost talking about being an
entrepreneur as a hobby they're right it
almost takes out this is a thing this is
something and I just got goosebumps oh
I'm starting to get into a new thing
that I'm trying to figure out how to
articulate I'm doing it here out loud
for the first time which is when does
entrepreneurship or going for it take on
more fun whether it's very practical
because you're you asking for the 35 to
55 year old demo or when it's you're
still under 30 in your 20s but you've
confided into or picked a job route when
is actually in hobby land exactly what
is it like you like having your side
hustle and you're enjoying it but it
doesn't need to or have to become your
life and you don't have to make a Billy
right for you to be happy so I what I
would say is if you're up at night and
you can't breathe and you have to do
your thing well then you just might not
be good enough I mean think about all
the people we've seen on American Idol
who are like I got my whole life and I
knew I was going to be win the use and
you're all pomp t like back when people
watched it you know and and you're like
and you're like you can do it and then
she's like ah and you're like now and
like there's it's delusional right well
we have that an entrepreneur land again
emails every day I mean people every day
who are delusional about their skill set
I desperately desperately desperately
want to be the small forward of the New
York Knicks if I truly acted on that
like if right now at 38 I'm like
overseas trying to be on the 13th man on
the bench of an Italian B League team
that's not going to work right like I'm
not going it's not going to happen no
matter what I do and so I think the
answer to your question for me to make
it as valuable for them as possible is
are you willing to get comfortable and
accepting that you're in hobby zone
versus transitioning into that zone and
if you are well then in a weird way back
to your question these tie-in you can
have a best of both worlds right if
you're asking me like how to get
somebody to become self-aware enough
and not delusional that they're hurting
themselves that's not something I know
how to really fully answer cool thank
you
thanks do you want to jump in on the
show I know you came in late great wanna
take a selfie real quick yes it was
actually hold on everyone don't edit
d-roc all right you got it how's my fro
you look amazing thank you though you
did it you really know I love it all
right um tell everybody you tell the
Vayner nation who you are
hi vaynernation I'm Ali de Castro at
Miss LED on Twitter um so my question is
I'm actually really glad I'm asking it
one on one and not in front of the
audience and now that it's being filmed
yeah it's his way huger so anymore huge
so um I have a job that I absolutely
love I actually worked for Remax of New
Jersey who spoke for us yeah be much
right before I got hired so I just
missed you um I love my job I love what
I do I do social media and graphic
design I work with our SEO company we
develop content and of course I want to
get into doing my own thing doing my own
blog starting my own hustle and I have
this and I know it stems from a fear of
failure but I have this really hard time
I get like crippled when it comes to
like executing and I know you're
probably gonna like just do it go for it
do your thing and I know so well but I
just need to hear it like I need you to
look me at my teeth and tell me do you
want it yes I do and so literally you're
just scared to fail I mean if you want
to go deep with me I'll go deep it's who
are you scared to fail in front of is
your mom is your best friend is your
sister that's the only thing that holds
people back something happened to me
like everybody thinks like oh I'm so
nice look what I'm doing right now to
this I don't give a shot without anybody
else's opinion
so Rallye that I'm never scared because
if I fail and people like say hahaha I'm
like I don't even it doesn't even
register it doesn't in the same way when
people like you changed my life you're
the best I'm able to be grounded because
it also doesn't it you know I'm kind of
in that middle zone right like not too
high not too low which would confuse
people based on my energy but I equally
care about every comment in the YouTube
section of this episode I'm going to
read them but if somebody says you blow
and like this format stinks and you
should let the rock at it you know
that's gonna be okay like and so if you
want to get deep with me I know for a
fact that you're it because you've
already given it to me that it's to feel
fair a feeling the fear of failure
now the question becomes to whom and
what I would do is and you'll have to
share that with the world I'd go talk to
that person up front the best practical
advice I've ever given in this scenario
and it works over and over is you go and
you sit down with that and say or Johnny
or your boyfriend or your sister or a
girlfriend I don't care who it is right
you sit down you look them in the face
say I'm about to do this and the only
reason I haven't done it for the last
year is I don't want to let you down
because entrepreneurship is a crapshoot
and I'm not sure if I'm going to win but
long term I'm gonna win and I just need
to make sure if I fail on this step that
your response to me doesn't crush me to
never let me have a second at-bat
because that's what it is okay
right yes that's it all right all right
cool you got all right everybody thank
you so much for watching this improv
show them they look so cool this looks
really cool thanks for uh thanks for
watching episode 26 question of the day
you know what you really inspired me
with that question that got really we
don't know if the camera caught the
little tearing but I got that was fun
for me and that was like it was really
you know what I'm glad I thank you so
much because that's a piece of advice
have never shared with my audience I've
shared it privately but like that's why
this show is like what I want you know
like this is why you got you guys are
massively helping me because a lot of
you let's go
I'm over here what uh you guys are
helping me massive I just want you guys
to know this too because you're getting
new stuff out of me because you're
making me more creative by asking these
things so I'm gonna ask that who's that
person in your life right now that you
so desperately don't want to let down
that you admire and love so much that it
may be holding you back from somebody or
something excuse me I want you to leave
that in the comments because I have a
funny feeling if you leave that comment
it may start the process to a very very
good thing you keep asking questions
I'll keep answering them
oh crap wait subscribe do do I need
subscriptions because I can't push this
many right hooks in social